ก็สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้อง
เรียมคุณครับนักเรียนเย้คนอากลับมาเจอกับ
เกียร์ที่นี่จะกลับน้องเรียมในห้องช่อง
อะไรครับเบอร์ไทยค่ะ
ไทยโอเคครับฮ่าๆอยู่ข้างบนอยู่บนหลังคาเค
Compressor  World  Thai  R ไปเรียนภาษา
ไทยกับเกียร์ปกรณ์น้องเหลี่ยมกันวันนี้
วันนี้วันอะไรครับเรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกัน
วันอะไรครับวันนี้วันนี้
มีวันพุธใช่มั้ยปัญหาวะวุฒิโอเควันพุธวัน
พุธที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้วันพุธที่
12 ค่ะใช่แล้ววันนี้วันพุธที่ 12 ครับใน
วันพุธที่ 12 เดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้เดือน
มกราคมค่ะแต่เดือนนี้เดือนมกราคมนะครับปี
ปีคศอะไรครับปีคศ
2010  22
52 พัน 20  2 โอเคครับแล้วปีพศอะไรครับ
พ.ศ
2565 ค่ะ
[เพลง]
2565 นะครับแค่อ้าแล้วเอ่อโอเค Beach
พ.ศ
2565 เดือนนี้เดือนมกราคมใช่ไหมลล์แล้ว
เดือนเดือนนี้เดือนมกราคม
เดือน
ที่แล้วเส้นที่แล้วเดือนที่แล้วเดือนอะไร
ครับเดือนที่แล้วเดือนธันวาคมเดือนที่
แล้วเดือนธันวาคมใช่ไหมครับหน้าเดือนนี้
เดือนมกราคมเดือนที่แล้วเดือนอาวาคมอ่ะ
แล้วเดือนหน้านะครับเดือนหน้าเดือนหน้า
เดือนอะไรครับเดือนหน้าเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
เดือนหน้าเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
โอเคโอเคอ่าเดือนหน้าเดือนกุมภาพันธ์กลับ
มาที่เดือนนี้เดือนนี้เดือนมกราคมใช่ไหม
ฮะอ่าครับมาวันนี้วัน
พุธใช่แล้ว 22k ไปเรียนภาษาไทยการเองตอน
นี้ตอนเที่ยงเขาเรียนภาษาไทยกันกี่โมง
ครับตอนนี้ตอนนี้
05:35 น
5:00 น 35 เป็นตอนเช้าหรือตอนเย็นครับ
หรือตอนเย็นตอนเย็นค่ะพระอาทิตย์ก็ออน
เย็นตอนเย็นพระอาทิตย์ตกตก
ฮะโอเคตอนเช้าพระอาทิตย์ขึ้น
ในขึ้นพระอาทิตย์หน้า
ไอ้ตอนเย็นโอเคตอนเช้า
ได้ครับณวันนี้วันนี้เพื่อที่มีเรื่องจะ
มาเล่าให้ฟังอ่ะเพื่อตี้ไปเที่ยวมาได้ไง
คิตตี้ไปเที่ยวอีกแหละ
บ่อยมากเที่ยวบ่อยจังไปเที่ยวบ่อยๆสนุกดี
อ่ะนักเรียนนักเรียนชอบไปเที่ยวไหม
เฮียตี้ทอช่อไปเที่ยวนี่
ชอบไปเที่ยวเชียงใหม่
ชอบเออภูเก็ต
ระยองขอไปเที่ยวระยองเชียงใหม่ภูเก็ตน่ะ
วันนี้พี่ตีจะอ่านเล่าเล่าเรื่องที่
ติไปเที่ยวไปเที่ยวเชียงราย
มีเพียงรายหยุดติดกับเชียงใหม่เชียงใหม่
เชียงรายอยู่ติดกันอีกน่าใช้ครับเที่ยง
ใหม่อยู่ภาคเหนือนิภาคเหนือนะ 5
เชียงใหม่อยู่ก็ไม่มีตรงนี้เป็นภาคเหนือ
อ่ะนี่คือประเทศไทยนะครับประเทศไทยประเทศ
ไทยเชียงใหม่อยู่ภาคเหนือเชียงใหม่อยู่
ตรงนี้จเชียงใหม่หาแล้วก็เชียงราย
เชียงรายจะหยุดติดกับเชียงใหม่จะอยู่ตรง
นี้
เคียงรายน่าอยู่ติดๆกันเฮ็ดที่อยู่ตรงนี้
พี่ตี้อยู่นนทบุรีรือขับรถไป
ขับรถตึ๊ดตึ๊ดตึ๊ดตึ๊ดตึ๊ดๆๆๆๆๆตื่นๆๆไป
เชียงรายใช่ครับรถไปเมื่อตายตาย I เวลา
กี่ชั่วโมงค่ะขับรถไปเชียงรายเรียกคิดว่า
ใช้เวลาประมาณประมาณประมาณ 10 ชั่วโมง
เขา 5 ที่เชียงรายเป็นภูเขา
เป็นภูเขา
ช้ายเป็นภูเขาต้องขับรถคืนผูกเขาคืนรู้
เขาให้ไปเที่ยงล่ะหายฮ่าๆๆ
เชียงใหม่เชียงใหม่ก็มีภูเขาแต่มีภูเขา
นิดหน่อยเชียงใหม่มีภูเขานิดหน่อยเหอะที่
บ้านบ้านของเรียงมหามีภูเขาไหมไม่มี
ภูเขา
1 ภูเขาเจน
ไม่มีภูเขาเลยใช่ไหมครับอ่าที่เชียงใหม่
เชียงรายมีภูเขานะครับฮะโอเคพี่ไปไปที่
เชียงรายไปดูอะไรนักเรียนรู้ไหมมี
เต็ม
ไปเคียงรายไป 10 นายไปดูอะไรใช่ไหมครับ
นี่เลขที่ไปดูอันนี้ครับนี่ต้องเตรียมเคย
เห็นเคยเห็นอันนี้ไหมอันนี้เรียกเรียก
อะไรครับอ๋อเตรียมเคยเห็นในทีวีขอใน PV
ครับว่าบอลลูนใช่ครับอันนี้เรียกบอลลูน
บอลลูนลูกใหญ่ลูกใหญ่มากนี่คนคนมีคนอยู่
ตรงนี้คนตัวนิดเดียวคนตัวนิดเดียว
บอลลูนลูกใหญ่บอลลูนลูกใหญ่บอลลูนรอลอย
เธอ
ลอยลอยอยู่บนท้องฟ้า
หน้าซ้ายครับรออยู่บนท้องฟ้า
สูง 100 สูงขึ้นไปบนท้องฟ้ามากทายเนอะได้
ครับ
เตรียมเห็นบอลลูนมีสีสวยมากๆๆใช่ครับ
บอลลูนมีหลายสีสวยมากใช่ครับ
เฮียติ๊ดถ่ายรูปบอลลูนมาด้วยที่พี่ไปไป
เที่ยวไปดูมาใช่ครับมาเดี๋ยวพี่เปิดรูป
บอลลูนหลายๆลูกให้ดูหน้ามีบอลลูนเยอะเลย
นี้มีบัลลูนเยอะเลยใช่ครับรูปที่เพียบพี่
ถ่ายมาจากทำอะไรอาหาร
วุคสวยดีมากๆใช้ครับสวยแล้วก็ใหญ่มาก
ตีตัวนิดเดียวพี่เดินอยู่แถวนี้เดิน
อยู่แถวนี้ตัวนี้ดีเดี๋ยวจะได้อ่านี่คนจะ
เดินอยู่ตรงนี้มีคนเยอะแยะอยู่อย่างนี้ไป
ดูเดียวอ่าใช่ครับทุกคนไปดูบอลลูนกัน
เรียงเห็นบอลลูนรูปหัวใจซ้อ
มีบอลลูนรูปหัวใจรูปหัวใจอยู่ตรงนี้หารูป
หัวใจเป็นรูปนี้นี่รูปหัวใจ
รูปหัวใจเนี่ยบอลลูนรูปหัวใจนะ
[เพลง]
เราก็มีบอลลูนสีเหลืองสีเหลืองใช่ครับมี
บอลลูนสีเหลืองหลายลูกเลยนิสีเหลือง
สีเหลืองอ่ะสีเหลืองเหมือนกันอ่ะใช่ครับ
บอลลูนสีฟ้า
ใช่ครับมีบอลลูนสีฟ้ามีบัลลูนสีเหลือง
บอลลูนบางลูกมีหลายสีนี่มีหลายสีสีแดงสี
ฟ้าสีขาวสีเหลืองสีเขียวมีหลายสีอยู่ใน
บอลลูนหน้า 1 ลูกชาย
เรียบเห็นบอลลูนรูป
ยานอวกาศ
ยุควิหารออกขออันนี้จะไปกอล์ฟถ้าเป็นยา
นอนกาจน่าใช้ครับกำลังกำลังลอยขึ้นไปลอย
ขึ้นไปบนท้องฟ้านะครับน่าจะลอยไปไม่ถึง
เอาอากาศ
เอาอากาศอยู่ตรงไหนครับเอาอากาศอ่ะเดี๋ยว
อันนี้นี้เป็นและก็โลกของเราใช่ไหมครับ
หน่ะเป็นโรคเดี๋ยวพี่วาดโลกเหมือนโลกไหม
โลกโลกมิดเอเชียใช่มั้ยโอเคอ่าเป็นโรค
อวกาศอยู่ข้างนอกนี้ครับ
เนี่ยเอ้ยอ้าแต่บอลลูนบอลลูนลอยอยู่แถว
นี้
อรุณไปไม่ถึงอวกาศไม่แบบไม่รุคันรู้แบบ
สุดอ๋อไม่บรรลุนไปไม่ถึงไปไม่ถึงใจครับ
ไม่ได้ไปเอาระหว่างไม่ถึงไปไม่ถึงใช่ครับ
หน้า
ฉันลอยลอยขึ้นมา
ได้ลอยขึ้นไปสูงใช้ครับ
นี่
ไอ้เสื้อตัวนี้
มี
งานบอลลูนอี้บอลลูกนี้กำลังเป่าอยู่ลูก
นี้ยังไม่ลอยไหมอ่าอ้า
ใช่หรอคะเป่าลมเข้าไปแต่ไม่ได้ใช้ปากเป่า
นะใช้ปากเป่าไม่ได้มารุ่นใหญ่เปล่า
เป่าไม่วายไม่ไหวได้ครับงานๆครับบอลลูน
ต้องใช้ครับใส่แว่นตาใส่แว่นด้วยใช่ก็
เพราะว่ามีมีพระอาทิตย์พระอาทิตย์ส่องแสง
แน่พระอาทิตย์ลองแต่งหน้าก็ร้อน
ร้อนร้อนนับเจ้าใส่แว่นตัดใส่แว่นเพราะ
ว่าเราจะรู้สึกแสบตาม
ฝ่ายครับอาดูแปลกตาเพราะเรามองบอลลูน
บอลลูนอยู่บนท้องฟ้าเรามองบัลลูนเราก็
เห็นพระอาทิตย์ด้วยก็แสบตาแสบก็เลยใส่
แว่น
หายแว่นแล้วก็โอเคไม่แสงตาห้าชายกับก็มอง
ได้มองได้หรือ
เพียงสิ้นหนาวหรอคะ
เฮียตี๋หนาวนิดหน่อยค่ามีใส่ผ้าพันคอคอนะ
ครับหน้าเพราะว่าที่ที่เชียงรายอากาศ
อากาศหนาวนิดหน่อยหนาวนิดหน่อยหนาวนิด
หน่อยประมาณกี่องศาค่ะอ้าประมาณตอนเทียบ
พี่ไปตอนนั้นน่าจะประมาณ 15  55 ไส้ Hub
15-20 ชาย
วาง 5 ถึง
25 องศาใช้ครับเลี่ยมหรือว่าอากาศดี
ใช่ครับอากาศดี
โอเคครับไปเชียงรายกับใครคะเรียงเห็นหน้า
คนบอกเลิกไล่เทียบที่อ๋ออ๋อใช่กับคนนี้
เป็นภรรยาพี่อาร์ตี้ไส้ซ้ายครับหน้าไปกับ
ภรรยาแล้วก็พาลูกไปด้วยถ้ามีลูกอีก 2 คน
พี่ตี้มีลูก 2 คนเป็นผู้ชายก็ไปด้วยใช้
ครับไม่อยากเสียตีพอเพียงดีก็แต่งงานแล้ว
High แล้วใช้งานหน้า
ก็ไปเที่ยวด้วยกันนะครับ
พี่
แล้วน้องเรียมรู้ไหมว่าบอลลูนลอยขึ้นไป
ลอยขึ้นไปบนท้องฟ้าได้ยังไง
ลอยขึ้นไป
เธอลอยขึ้นไปได้ยังไงครับ
เรียบเคยเห็นในทีวีจะมีไฟผู้ขอชายใช่ใช่ๆ
บัลลูนลอยขึ้นไปได้เพราะว่านี่ครับมีไฟมี
ไฟเขาใช้ไฟ
ใช้ไฟเป่าเข้าไปเห็นอ่าเปลี่ยนที่เปลี่ยน
สีเป็นสี
สีอะไรถึงจะมองชัดสีขาวแล้วกันนะเปลี่ยน
เป็นสีขาวนี่เปล่าไปเข้าไปเว็บไฟไปเป่า
เข้าไปในบอลลูนบอลลูนก็ทำให้อากาศร้อน
อากาศร้อนใช่ครับร้อนร้อนๆร้อนๆเพราะ
อากาศร้อนอากาศก็จะลอยขึ้นไปลอยขึ้นไปใช่
อากาศที่อยู่ในบอลลูนเนี่ยก็จะร้อนร้อน
ร้อนเพราะว่ามีไฟ
หน้าแล้วอะจะทำให้บอลลูนลอยขึ้นไป
ใช้ครับแล้วก็จะมีตักป้าตะกร้าอยู่ข้าง
ล่าง
ป้ายข้างล่างตรงนี้ตะกร้านะพี่อาร์ตี้ที
ให้ดูตะกร้านะรูปต่างๆๆๆนี่มีแต่กล้าอยู่
ตรงนี้ครับ
นี่มีแต่ป้าอยู่ตรงนี้ก็คนคนก็เข้าไปอยู่
ในตะกร้าตรงนี้
สายๆแล้วก็ลอยขึ้นไปพร้อมกับบอลลูนชายนี่
ครับเวลาเข้าไปในตะกร้าเข้าไปในตะกร้าเรา
ต้องปีนเข้าไป
ปีนปีนใช่ครับปีนขึ้นไปใช้เท้าเหยียบตรง
นี้เหยียบสีนาไอ้เท้าเหยียบตรงนี้แล้วก็
หยิบเหี่ยวเหยียบตรงนี้อ้าแล้วก็ก้าวขึ้น
ไปหาก้าวขึ้นไปในบอลลูนโอเค
เรียมมายก็
ไม่รู้เรียนคิดว่าแบบใช้บันไดอ๋อมีเอ่อ
ส่วนใหญ่จะใช้เหยียบตรงนี้เหยียบแล้วก็
ก้าวขึ้นไปไม่ได้ใช้บันไดใช่ครับ
ตอนแรกเรียนนึกว่าพี่อาร์ตี้มีมีบันไดแบบ
นี้มีบันไดแบบบันไดแบบนี้ใช่ไหมครับบันได
ที่บันไดแล้วก็เดินเดินเดินขึ้นบันไดขึ้น
บันไดใช่แล้วลงมาตรงนี้ใช่ไหมฮะไม่ใช่
บันไดไม่มีบันไดอ๋อ
แล้วเขาใช้แก๊สใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับใช้แก๊สนี่
มีแก๊สมีฐานแก๊สอยู่ในนี้
นิทานแก๊สอยู่ในนี้ครับมีตรงนี้เป็นสาว
แก๊ส
เป็นถังแก๊สที่เป็นถังแบบนี้อ่ะโอ้
นี่เป็นถ้าไปเราก็ต่อสายขึ้นไปต่อสายขึ้น
ไปตรง
ตรงนี้นี่ต่อทรายแก๊สมาตรงนี้ครับ
ๆแล้วก็จุดไฟ
มีเสียงไฟฟู
ไป
คนคนที่อยู่ในตะกร้าร้อนไหมค่ะหาคนที่
อยู่ในตะกร้าไม่ร้อนครับไม่ร้อนเพราะว่า
เขาว่าอากาศที่ร้อนอยู่ในอยู่ในบัลลูนอ๋อ
อ่ะอยู่ในบอลลูนคนที่อยู่ข้างล่างคนที่
อยู่ข้างล่างตรงนี้ไม่ร้อนไม่ร้อนเย็น
สบายครับเย็นสบายอยู่ข้างนอกนมเย็นแล้วก็
ลอยขึ้นไป
สูง 100 ขึ้นไปสูงก็
จะมีลมพัดแรงมีเวลาลอยขึ้นมาสูง
100 สูงก็จะมีลมพัดแรงดูนี่
ได้มีลมพัดลมพัดหน้า
ๆไปสูงประมาณกี่เมตรค่ะขึ้นไปสูงเงี้ยตี้
ไม่แน่ใจว่าสูงเท่าไหร่แต่คิดว่าน่าจะสูง
มากกว่า 10 เมตร 10  10 ถึง 20 เมตรนี่สิ
คิดว่าคิดว่าประมาณ
10-20 เมตรชายอาหาร 10 ถึง 20 เมตรยัง
ไม่แต่ไม่แบบทะลุออกไปเอาอากาศอ้าวไม่ออก
ไม่ออกเขา
เคี้ยว
เรียบสวยมั้ง
ไอได้ครับมีที่ที่เชียงรายทุกปีทุกปีปี 5
ตอนช่วงประมาณประมาณเดือนธันวาคม
ขอก็คือเดือนที่แล้วๆเดือนที่แล้ว
ธันวาคมพฤศจิกายนอะที่อากาศหนาวอากาศหนาว
ๆพันธุ์ 21 ก็จะมี 1 ครั้ง
ใช่ครับ 2022 ก็มี 1 ครั้งของไทยครับปีละ
1 ครั้งปีละ 1 ครั้งใต้ใช่ครับครูหน้าปี
ปีนี้ปี
2022 ก็มี 1 ครั้ง
ว่าเดี๋ยวน้องเรียมโรงเรียนเตรียมตัวไปดู
เผื่อพูดกันว่าเรียมไม่ไม่ชอบขับรถอ๋อไม่
ชอบขับรถ
ปีหน้าก็นั่งเครื่องบินไปได้บีมไปบินไป
ไม่ต้องขับบ่อยใช้
เชียงราย LINE ให้ครับเพียงรายจึงรายอยู่
ภาคเหนือมีอยู่พักหนึ่งเหนือนะครับนัก
เรียนอยู่ภาคไหนเรียงอยู่ภาคอีสาน
น้องเรียมอยู่ภาคอีสานภาคอีสานอยู่ตรงนี้
รองนี้ตรงนี้ก็นี้น้องเรียนอยู่ตรงนี้ใช่
ไหมครับ
เย้อยู่ภาคอีสานเชียงรายอยู่ภาคเหนือ
เรียนดีอยู่ภาคกลาง
[เพลง]
เตรียมก็ต้องแกนั่งเครื่องบิน
ไปถ้าไม่อยากขับรถไม่อยากขับรถก็นั่ง
เครื่องบินไป
เครื่องบินเนี่ยตีวาดเครื่องไปอ่าได้ไหม
เรื่องบิน
ปลาย 5
ค่ะ
วันนี้ได้รู้จักแล้วนะครับอ่าเบียร์ที่
คิดว่านักเรียนหลายๆคนนักเรียนทุกๆก็ต้อง
รู้จัก
ขอแค่แล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้านะครับคราวหน้า
เราจะกลับมาเรียนรู้เรื่องอะไรเดี๋ยวค่อย
ติดตามกันนะครับสำหรับวันนี้นะครับพี่ตี้
กับน้องเรียนก็หมดเวลาแล้วหมดเวลาแล้ว
เฮ้อต้องลาไปก่อนครับมาพบกันใหม่ขาวนะ
ครับสำหรับวันนี้สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะค่ะ
พี่
ทำนักเรียนบ๊ายบายอ่าวว